RACHEL: WELCOME BACK TO "FOX &
FRIENDS."
THE IDEA IS UPDATING MASK
GUIDANCE FOR SCHOOLS NOW
ADVISING, QUOTE:  UNIVERSAL
INDOOR MASKING FOR ALL TEACHERS,
STAFF AND STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
VACCINATION STATUS, END QUOTE.
BUT SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
OPTING TO LEAVE THE MASKING
DECISION UP TO PARENTS.
JOINING US NOW IS JUSTIN DAVIS A
MEMBER OF THE GASTON COUNTY
SCHOOL BOARD IN NORTH CAROLINA
AND BRIAN WHOSE TWO KIDS ARE
ENROLLED IN KIDNAPPING GEORGE
COUNTY SCHOOLS IN VIRGINIA.
SO I’M GOING TO START WITH YOU,
JUSTIN.
YOUR BOARD VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO
LET PARENTS HAVE THAT OPTION.
OF COURSE, THIS WAS PRIOR TO THE
CDC’S NEW RECOMMENDATIONS ON
MASKING IN SCHOOLS.
COULD YOU EXPECT THAT DECISION
TO STAND OR DO YOU THINK THAT
THINGS WILL BE REVISED GIVEN THE
CDC’S LATEST ANNOUNCEMENT?
>> WELL, I APPRECIATE YOU HAVING
ME ON THIS MORNING.
AND THANK YOU.
RACHEL: OF COURSE.
I THINK PARENTS ARE BEST SUITED
TO MAKE DECISIONS FOR WHAT’S
RIGHT FOR THEIR CHILD.
AND THE CDC, OF COURSE, IS A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION.
AND HAS GIVEN THAT GUIDANCE BUT
YOU KNOW, I DON’T NECESSARILY
BELIEVE WE NEED A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL POLICY FOR EVERYONE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WHAT’S RIGHT FOR THE CITIZENS OF
GASTON COUNTY AND THE STUDENT OF
OUR COUNTY IS NOT NECESSARILY
THE SAME AS IN SAN FRANCISCO,
CALIFORNIA OR NEW YORK, NEW
YORK.
AND IT’S OKAY WE DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY IN GASTON COUNTY
THAN THEY DO ELSEWHERE.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE THAT LOCAL CONTROL THESE
ARE THE TYPE OF DECISIONS THAT
SHOULD REMAIN WITH LOCAL CONTROL
AND I HOPE THAT WILL CONTINUE.
RACHEL: THAT MAKES SENSE.
SOME COUNTIES DOWN BY THE BORDER
SEEING 900 PERCENT SURGE IN
COVID CASES SO, YEAH.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, ONE SIZE
DOESN’T FIT ALL.
LET’S TALK WITH YOU NOW, BRIAN,
YOU HAVE HOW MANY CHILDREN?
>> I HAVE TWO CHILDREN.
RACHEL: TWO CHILDREN?
DO YOU LIKE THIS DECISION OF
LEAVING IT UP TO THE PARENTS TO
DECIDE, MAKING MASK-WEARING
OPTIONAL IN SCHOOLS?
>> YES.
I THINK IT’S THE BEST THING TO
DO FOR ALL PARENTS BECAUSE AS A
PARENT I WOULD RATHER BE IN
CHARGE OF MAKING THE DECISION
THE HEALTH DECISIONS FOR MY
CHILDREN.
I DON’T THINK THE GOVERNMENT HAS
A PLACE IN THAT.
IT DOESN’T HAVE A ROLL IN THAT
AS FAR AS I’M CONCERNED.
AND THERE IS A LOT OF, YOU KNOW,
THERE IS A LOT OF QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING THE EFFICACY OF
MASKS IN GENERAL.
AND BUT I DON’T THINK THAT -- I
DON’T THINK -- I THINK PARENTS
SHOULD HAVE THE OPTIONS IF A
PARENT WANTS THEIR CHILD TO WEAR
A MASK, THAT’S OKAY.
BUT IF THEY DON’T WANT THEM TO
WEAR A MASK, THAT SHOULD BE
OKAY.
TOO.
AND I SHOULD HAVE THAT ABILITY
TO, YOU KNOW, IF I THINK THAT MY
CHILDREN ARE STILL SAFE GOING TO
SCHOOL WITHOUT A OF COURSE THAT,
THAT SHOULD BE A RIGHT.
RACHEL: BRIAN, I’M GOING TO STAY
WITH YOU FOR A SECOND BECAUSE OF
YOUR TWO CHILDREN.
I GET LETTERS ALL THE TIME.
I’M A MOTHER OF NINE.
I HAVE SEEN THE IMPACT OF
MASK-WEARING FOR MY OWN KIDS.
I SEE INCREASES IN ACNE, GERMS.
I GOT A LETTER YESTERDAY FROM A
MOM, A GRANDMOTHER ACTUALLY
SAYING HER GRAND KIDS HAVE
DENTAL PROBLEMS BECAUSE WEARING
THE MASK THAT LONG THERE IS SOME
SORT OF ISSUES THAT DENTISTS ARE
NOW SEEING UPTICK IN ISSUES WITH
THAT SO THERE ARE -- AND THEN
NOT TO MENTION ANXIETY AND OTHER
THINGS.
WHAT KIND OF IMPACT IS WEARING A
MASK, YOU KNOW, LAST YEAR, FOR
EXAMPLE, HAVE WITH YOUR CHILDREN
AND WHAT WOULD CONCERN YOU IF
THAT WERE TO CHANGE AND IT WAS
NOT OPTIONAL FOR YOUR CHILDREN
MOVING FORWARD?
>> WELL, BECAUSE OF THE MASK
MANDATE OF LAST SCHOOL YEAR, WE
DID NOT SEND OUR KIDS BACK WHEN
WE HAD THE OPTION TO.
AND OTHER REASONS FOR THAT MY
WIFE STAYS AT HOME FOR OTHER
REASONS WE DID IT THAT WAY.
BUT, YEAH, I THINK THAT IF THEY
DO REQUIRE MASKS, YOU KNOW, I
THINK IT’S BEST FOR OUR
CHILDREN, ESPECIALLY MY OLDEST,
TO BE IN SCHOOL AND, YOU KNOW,
WE WOULD HAVE TO JUST TRY TO
WORK AROUND IT.
MAYBE IF THE SCHOOL BOARD WOULD
ALLOW FOR AN EXEMPTION FOR
PARENTS WHO THINK THAT IT’S
UNSAFE FOR THEIR CHILDREN TO
WEAR ACTIVIST THAT.
THAT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE, TOO.
I DON’T THINK AS MR. DAVIS SAYS,
IT’S NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
RACHEL: YEAH.
JUSTIN, BRIEN, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING AND
GIVING YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
I’M CERTAINLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
MORE SMILES AND LESS MASKS
MOVING INTO THE SCHOOL YEAR IN